well I hope you've been having a good
conference so far and when I was asked
to speak here and I was going to speak
to their kind of main room and there's a
lot of you and I guess you all work in
different parts of the stack and I
thought what I would talk about is
really where we are as we head into the
last quarter of 2018 as we look forward
to 2019 where we are with CSS layout
because we've had some fairly big shifts
in that landscape over the last few
years
last year CSS was actually 20 years old
this makes me feel very old because I
remember when we didn't have CSS I am
someone who built websites with tables
for layout and I remember CSS coming
along and just for fonts and sort of
saying oh you know I'm not sure about
this not sure about this store so I've
kind of grown up with CSS and I've seen
what's happened you know how things have
progressed over time and at some point
you know we moved away from the whole
tables for layout thing and we started
doing stuff with CSS and doing sinister
layer and all our websites got really
simple looking like our well this is the
web this is what the web looks like and
I think actually a lot of how we'd so
things would say a web like actually
stem from a technical limitation the
fact that by using floats in absolute
positioning there's actually very
limited things that we can do and when
you look it at you what we've managed to
achieve by really hacking around with
floating things you know left and right
and making sure they're not too big and
that we don't end up with more than a
hundred percent because then all sorts
of weird things happen to our layout
everything that we've done so far on the
web to do layout has really been this
kind of series of hacks and for the
first time you know over the last couple
years with things like grid coming out
we've actually got what we could call a
true layout system for the web and that
makes a huge change to everything that
we're doing and so when we think about
this system for layout I think most
people would probably think about things
like grid and flex bar
and that's really all based on top of
this idea of flow layout of normal flow
of the way that things just behave by
default we don't start doing any layout
and we've got things like multiple
column layout but you have to mention
because that's one of the specs that I
edit but that's a specification that's
there to do that kind of column based
layout so they're the big specs they're
the things that we would think if
someone said you know what is there in
CSS layout today you might think oh well
as CSS grid is flexbox but those things
are held together by some other
specifications and they're really really
key to understanding the big specs that
we talked about we've got things like
writing modes which are really hard to
talk about unless you start thinking
about logical properties and values
we've got box alignment and we've got
CSS sizing intrinsic extrinsic sizing
which is really important now that we're
talking about layouts that can kind of
work out its sizing itself you know
we're not taking control
we're not giving things a width and
pushing them around to make something
that looks like a grid we're actually
letting the browser kind of workout a
lot of that stuff for us so sizing
becomes really key and we also have
these ways of providing really great
experiences to our users whatever
they're using to view our websites
because the web is kind of exploded with
all these different devices you know I
remember way back when I started with
the web and my first computer had a 640
by 480 screen and then I got a better
screen that was you know one or two four
by seven six eight and I felt marvelous
you know it was enormous and I couldn't
wait for everybody else to have as big a
screen as I had got you know what
websites could I create if I had all
that screen space to deal with and just
as everyone starts to get these nice big
screens they also got phones and it
certainly we were having to deal again
with the fact that some people had a
very small screen in front of them and
now of course we're getting webpage is
displayed on watches and it we can't
really sort of think well how we're
going to support all of these
different things we have to develop in a
way that is going to cope with the fact
that these exist and half of them we
don't really know what they are and so
we've got things like media queries and
then we've got feature queries the
ability to detect what their CSS is
available so these things are all really
important and then we can't forget some
of the other things that are making
their way into browsers
we've got CSS shapes taking us away from
everything looking like a little box got
transforms things like scroll snapping
and variable font and we're talking
about layout here but things like
variable fonts can have a huge impact on
our layouts you know being used
creatively
and so in this talk I really want to
look at some of those specifications
that actually pull together our big
layout specs and you'll see plenty of
grids and flex box code but I think it's
really important to look at these things
that pull these other specs together
because actually a lot of the things
that we think are confusing about grid
and flexbox for example and it's sort of
understood through things like writing
modes so let's have a look at writing
modes because it shouldn't matter which
way up your component is if we've got a
grid and we turn it on its side like
we're using a vertical writing mode
there's no reason why that grid
shouldn't behave in exactly the same way
you know tipped over on its side so
writing mode is actually a really good
place to begin an exploration of new
layout because even if you actually
never use a writer mode other than the
default understanding writing mode tells
you a lot about how grid and flexbox
actually work because these layout
methods have got writing mode support
bakes in because they've been developed
sort of since the point at which we
thought we'll hang on people actually
use vertical writing modes perhaps we
should have layout methods that cope
with that so a horizontal top to bottom
writing mode like English or Arabic you
know a left-to-right or right-to-left
language it doesn't matter which way the
text runs if it's horizontal then we
have an inline dimension which runs
horizontally the inline dimension that's
the way that your text
in the writing mode that you happen to
be using so if that's the in line
dimension then the block dimension is
the direction in which blocks layout
down the page in that writing mode so if
we take a vertical writing mode then the
in line dimension is running down the
page top to bottom so that because
that's the way that the sentences flow
in that writing mode and the block
dimension is going to be running
horizontally
now you might use a writing mode to
typeset some text in that writing mode
but you could also use it creatively you
could it's quite common in in print to
see you know a headline running down the
side of the page or you can do that with
writing mode you can use writing modes
in a creative way and once you start to
work with those different writing modes
the fact that web design is essentially
tides the physical dimensions of our
screen starts to become a little bit
weird so I've got here a simple grid
layout now if I was to turn that into a
vertical writing mode what's going to
happen then is that the grid is kind of
gonna flip but the width that's applied
to it is going to remain relative to the
viewport it's not going to go with the
whole grid so what I can use is a
logical property a replacement for width
which is in line size so now the in line
size the size in the inline Direction is
500 pixels so the whole grid kind of
flips over on its side and it all kind
of remains relative to the flow
direction and that's what's really
important about these writing modes and
about logical properties is we've got
these mappings for things which are tied
to the physical dimensions of the screen
and tying them to make them kind of flow
relative there's a whole bunch of these
there's an entire spec all of them and
this spec is very readable because
essentially all it's doing is saying oh
well you know you've got these things
which are physical properties well here
is the equivalent as a logical property
it's all kind of coming into browsers
Firefox at the moment I think has the
best support for logical properties and
values but they're being rolled out in
other browsers because once we're
dealing with different writing modes it
all just becomes very weird to be
dealing with width once you've tipped
something over on its side I've written
a bunch of stuff about this this article
has got a load of demos and things in
and the resources of this talk I'll give
you at the end a link to all of these
things but there's lots of demos you can
play around and if you use Firefox
they'll all work and you can see how
logical properties and values will work
but they're just mappings essentially
for things that we already have and in
reality you're going to be using both
things because sometimes you do want
stuff tied to the dimensions of the
screen other times you want it to follow
the way the content is going and so then
we have box alignment because once we
understand writing modes and realize
that our layouts are not pinned to the
top left of the screen then alignment
starts to make a lot more sense and the
thing with the alignment property is
there's a bit of history there when we
first got flexbox we were all very
excited because suddenly we could
properly Center things both horizontally
and vertically it was like this spec it
appeared and that was the most important
thing about flexbox was the ability to
censor things we've been waiting a long
time for that is fair
so those properties appeared in flexbox
and what happened was it's you know
obvious so they're actually gonna be
more useful to be used across other
layout methods so they've been removed
from the flexbox spec and put into this
boxed alignment spec which means that we
can use the same alignment properties
across any layout methods and the one
that really comes to mind of course is
grid layout which is why if you know it
about flexbox you start using grid and
you're like oh you know this is this is
very similar a lot of things work in the
same way but one of the things that
people say they're very confused about
when they look at the alignment
properties in grid and flexbox they say
well when do i align things and when do
I justify them we've got these sets of
properties are we aligning where we
justifying which access are we dealing
with so we'll start with grid
if you've ever found alignment confusing
and flexbox it is much easier to look at
grid first because with grid we always
have two axes and they kind of stay in
the same place so we can sort of work
out what the alignment does in grid
fairly easily so if your properties
begin with a line they work on the block
access it doesn't matter if your block
axis is like in English and is running
down the page or your block axis is in a
vertical writing mode and so is running
across the page you align on the block
access and you justify therefore on the
inline axis now I remember that because
I think about text justification if
you're going to justify your text in an
editor then you'd be doing that along
the sentence that's the inline direction
so that's where we justify so we can
have a look at how that works in grid so
if we use a line self the default is
stretched so we get those kind of full
height columns if we align self to start
then on the block Direction we go to the
start to the start edge there if we
align self to the end we're going to go
to the end edge of their axes and if we
Center we get our nice century so that's
all on the block access and so then if
we justify then we're dealing with the
inline axis so we justify self Center
and that other box goes right into the
middle and it's being centered in that
grid area that it's sat in and if we
justify self start then it goes to the
start now so then if we look at a
different writing mode if we go into a
writing mode vertical RL and I'm already
using in line size there so the box is
going to tip over you can see the
alignment properties work in exactly the
same way because we're still dealing
with the block and the inline axis
really usefully if you're working with
grid layout you want to be using Firefox
and you want to use the grid inspector
I'm inspecting my grid here and you can
see how all of the lines of the grid and
the tracks they're all apparent and you
can see them you can work out when
you're special needing alignment and
you're pushing things around inside that
box it's really handy to be able to see
what the grid
is that you're aligning in and so
definitely even if you don't normally
use Firefox for development
you know chrome have gone down the lines
of giving us really great tools for
dealing with performance and so on
Firefox are putting a lot of work into
designer tools so things like the grid
inspector the CSS shapes editor or
really useful stuff if you're designing
for the web and you want to play around
in the browser so some other things you
might be working with and we have
languages which run right-to-left and
that affects things like grid layout and
alignment - if you're working in a right
to left language or for some reason
you've just changed the direction which
is pretty less likely and you're then
using you know justify items so we've
got just a fightin start if we're
working left to right the start is on
the left hand side if we change our
direction to right-to-left then start is
on the right hand side because it works
with the writing mode and the direction
of the text and flexbox is exactly the
same so then when we just fight items
end that actually goes to the left hand
side if we're in a right to left
language and there's something else we
might want to align with grid and that's
the grid tracks themselves we tend to
think of grid layouts and we've got you
know the entire area is taken up by grid
tracks and they completely fill the grid
container but your tracks might not take
up all of the available space and in
that case you need to decide what to do
with the leftover space you've got some
grid tracks and then we've got a bit of
space left over here I've got some space
the grid tracks by default or aligned to
start in both the block and inline
dimension and we've got that bit of
space either side of them at the end of
the tracks and at the bottom of the
tracks there's a little bit of space
left over so we use a line content on
the block axis again to deal with that
space so if the tracks are moved to the
ends and the space is put at the
beginning the content properties are all
about space distribution and we can send
to them so when you're dealing with a
line content and
certified content what you're doing is
you're dealing with available space
we've got no available space nothing is
actually going to happen because there's
nothing to share out and so we get that
sort of proper centering of our tracks
so if we go to space between the tracks
all kind of blow apart and our gaps all
get bigger and if we look in the grid
inspector again you can see how those
tracks and the actual gaps in between
have spread out and also any items that
span over those tracks they also spread
out so this is something to be aware of
if you're spacing out tracks in grid
layout things are going to get bigger
than you expected and again you know
Firefox good inspector showing us what's
actually going on there and letting us
make decisions about our design so in
grid I think that those properties seem
fairly consistent you know once we
remember that we're working on the block
and the inline axis and which properties
are which it's fairly straightforward
flexbox is a little bit more complicated
because we can mess around with our flex
direction and so in Flex box it is much
easier to think about the main axis and
the cross access and so the main axis is
the axis that you use when you set your
Flex direction if you say Flex Direction
row that's your main axis if you say
Flex Direction column that's your main
axis and a row will always be in the
inline direction in your writing mode so
a row in English is running horizontally
and a row in vertical writing mode is
going to be running up and down the page
on the cross axis we've got all three
properties we've got a line content if
we've got rapt flex items you've got a
line surfing the line items we'll have a
look at those on the main axis we've
only got justified content because in
Flex box were just dealing with space
distribution so if we look at Flex box
and we use justify content on the main
axis so here I'm working with a row and
I'm going to move all my items to the
end and the space goes before them and
if we do space between the space is
shared out in between the items and it's
nice and flexible
if we change the flex direction to
column I've got a height there so I've
got some extra space then it's working
exactly the same we were using justify
content in the direction of the Flex
direction and we've got this space and
we're spacing it out between and just as
with grid if we change our writing mode
it all just flips around and it all
behaves in exactly the same way because
we care about writing modes so then to
note there's no so there's no justify
self or justify items in Flex box
because you're dealing with items as a
group on the main axis you're not
dealing with separate items in Flex box
but on the cross axis you can have
wrapped Flex items that wrap round and
if you have wrapped Flex items and
you've got some extra space then you've
got some space to distribute so on the
cross axis we can use the align content
property and it works exactly the same
as justified content if we've got some
spare space we can then use that
property to share out the space to move
the items around to Center them to give
them space between and once again it
behaves in exactly the same way if
you're working in a vertical writing
mode and see your columns are running
across the page now on the cross axis
that's where you might want to align
your items against each other your Flex
container has a height of some sort
something's defining the height it might
be that as in this case the tallest item
is giving that liner height or it could
be that you've given the Flex container
a height itself so once you've got a
height you can then align the items
against each other so you can align them
to flex start so instead of stretching
to the height of the Flex container they
all hop up and go to the start and if
you line into Flex end as you can see
we're working with a line so we're
working on the cross access and dealing
with our items if you change the Flex
direction to column then it works
exactly the same way because our cross
access is now running across the screen
and so we can move our items around
that's access and this of course works
in exactly the same way we go there are
writing modes and we can switch it
around with writing modes and columns go
in the way that columns run in that
writing mode and it all works in the
same way so alignment is pretty neat
when I introduced the alignment spec I
said well the alignment properties were
taken out of the flexbox spec and they
were put into their own specs they could
be used by other layout methods now
they've got you know implementation in
grid so we can use those alignment
methods in grid layout they are also
specified for block layout and that
would mean that you could just have a
box inside another box and use the
alignment properties to Center it at the
moment there isn't any browser
implementation of that so if you have
you know one thing that you want to
Center inside another thing the best way
to do that at the moment is to turn the
outer into a Flex container and then you
can use the flex box properties to do
your proper vertical and horizontal
centering in the future we won't have to
make that step of also making the thing
a Flex container because we'll just be
able to do alignment on block layout and
but there's no real problem in making
containers flex containers it's just a
little bit weird that you have to do
that to make things Center at some point
in the future we'll get there and we'll
be able to do that but something we are
getting as part of box alignment in the
Box alignment spec as well as all those
nice alignment properties getting moved
from flex box also the gap feature which
shows up in grids and in multi call
that's also been moved into box
alignment so this idea of having gaps
gutters between items when the grid spec
first appeared it didn't have any idea
of gutters and this is something I
really pushed for that we should be able
to specify a gap between grid items
because that's a kind of normal thing
that you want to do in InDesign and so
we've now got a row gap column gap and
gap specified in the box alignment
property it box lament spec if you've
worked with grid layout you will know
that we
grids gap grid row gap and grid column
gap kind of grid prefixed they've been
renamed as just column gap row gap and
gap but those pre fixed grid versions
will live forevermore as aliases because
they've been around already and people
have shipped things using them so you
don't need to worry about that it's kind
of for backwards compatibility reasons
we'll keep them but the nice thing about
those gap properties been part of box
alignment is that we will get them in
flex box now the only browser which has
started to implement the gap properties
for flex box is Firefox it's in Firefox
nightly at the moment I think it's going
into the next shipping release and
you'll then be able to do gaps between
your Flex items without having to do
monkey negative margins on the outside
and margins in between the items so
that's going to be really nice but it's
also a great example of how specs are
kind of evolving you know we're coming
up with some CSS in one specification
and then it's sort of making its way out
into other specs where it becomes
obvious that we need it that's kind of a
bit of process and things that are
happening and people ask me all the time
you know should I use grid or flexbox
and as you can see these things have so
many common features the answer really
is use both or either but use the one
that works best no one ever asks me
whether they should use font size or
color and it's kind of like that you
know use the layout method that works
we're not picking between bootstrap and
foundation here it's all just CSS so use
the use the method that works and the
best way to find out which method works
best with the components you're building
is just to build it you know build it
see yeah Oh actually this is really
two-dimensional so maybe it's not a Flex
component it's a grid component and it
doesn't matter what sort of component
you're building you can have grid
components there's tiny little things if
it's two-dimensional it's probably grid
if you just want something squishy and
flexible it's probably for xbox and this
crossover there
but play around because the more of this
stuff that you build the more bukhov yes
you look at thing Ed's
design and say that's definitely grid or
that's definitely for Xbox and Ivan
really that note sizing is another area
where we've gained this consistency
between layout methods but it really
exposes the difference in terms of how
we've learned to size things in the past
because our new layout methods are
flexible we've already seen how they
distribute space between items and they
also can a distribute space inside items
so a lot of demos out there for grid
they give you something like this and it
looks like the fr unit if you have three
one fr tracks you've got three equal
width tracks and that's not really quite
what you've got you've only got three
equal width tracks if you've got equal
sized items in those tracks if we put a
very long word that doesn't break into
one of our tracks then we don't have
three equal sized tracks at all and
that's because grid is sizing things
based on Auto saying well what size is
the thing in this track and how much
space have we got left to distribute if
you actually want equal sized tracks
then you're going to need to use min max
and give the minimum size zero so you're
saying this thing has no size and its
maximum is one fr and that will give you
equal sized tracks it may well cause
overflows and that's the thing about
these new layout methods they're trying
not to cause messy overflows they're
trying to take your content and display
in the best way possible if you decide
as the web designer that you want to do
something different that's fine but by
default we're trying to display things
in a good way
and flexbox even more than that I think
flexbox really you know it's all about
I've got some stuff please just display
it in a reasonable manner don't overflow
it all over the place you know I don't
poking out of the box and so if your
flex basis is Auto then growing happens
from auto the contents given a size it's
sort of its max content size and then we
work out you know whether we need to
take space away or add space to let it
fill the container and if you
don't want that you make your flex base
a zero if your flex base is zero just
like in grid we're saying this thing has
got no size please share out all of the
space equally but flex box at heart is
kind of squishy and it's just for
putting the things into boxes and making
them sort of work out well and if you
are putting widths on all of your flex
items or specifying the Flex basis you
know as an absolute length to try and
make everything line up with something
else
then it's quite likely that you probably
want grid which is that you know that
layout method that does line things up
there with everything else I could talk
about sizing a lot to have entire talks
or I just talk about how big things are
and I've written up a lot of that for
Smashing Magazine
I think sizing is very very important to
understand to really use new layout well
and I think this sort of clever squishy
sizing of flexbox and grids it does mean
that we can get away with fewer media
queries it means that we can allow grid
and flexbox to squish and grow and to
distribute space inside the items to
distribute space in between the items
without having to add lots of
breakpoints but we can enhance that
layout with the use of major queries
quite often people seem to be very very
desperate not to use any media queries
and so know that they're still useful
you might not need as many you might not
need lots and lots of tiny breakpoints
but they can really help us enhance the
layout and and kind of accommodate all
of these different types of devices that
we have and we've actually got a new
media queries spec level for media
queries which brings us some new
functionality that we can use and we
have this idea of media features in the
older spec we sort of had this idea it's
got a media types you kind of got prints
and and different kinds but they're very
very broad and actually you don't really
care what the thing is you care what
features it has because there's quite a
lot of crossover you know people are
viewing web pages on essentially epub
readers or on televisions
or we've got laptops that have
touchscreens you know there are all
these different devices and they kind of
all cross over so it's a kind of bad
thing to be looking at well how big is
the screen or it must be a touchscreen
because you know my laptop's got a
touchscreen it's not a phone so what
we're doing is we're saying we've got
these media features what features does
this environment have and one of those
media features which actually has been
implemented in various browsers is a
detect the type of pointer the user has
because that's useful information has
someone got a fine pointer which is like
a mouse so you can click very accurately
on small things Oh
or have you got a coarse pointer you're
using your finger to touch things and
drag things around so that's you know
two different types of ways of
interacting with the content that's a
useful thing for us to be able to detect
you know have we've got that coarse
pointer or a fine pointer so we can work
out how our user is interacting with the
application or site that we've built and
maybe change things perhaps make the hit
areas larger if we know that someone is
using a touchscreen and along with media
queries it's all very well knowing that
the user has a certain type of device or
how big that device is or you know how
they're interacting with it that's a
useful thing for us to know but we also
have this idea of well what CSS has the
user got you know if I do a really fancy
grid layout does the user get that do
they get something else we never really
know and we're never going to know so
what we need is a way for us to ask the
browser exactly what CSS it supports and
that's what feature queries do they let
us say hey web browser
do you support grid do you support
shapes do you support this fancy new CSS
that we haven't even thought of yet and
then if the browser does support it we
can use it and if it doesn't then the
fallback CSS will be used and they kind
of look like this they just look like a
media query except we're saying app
supports do you support and then
whatever you're looking for and property
value
which means that you can get quite
fine-grained if you know that's you know
some feature of a specification isn't
supported you can just look for that you
could look for prefix things if you know
the few that are still around so you can
find out whether the browser supports
something and then do something because
of that and that works really well
because we've got really good support
now for feature queries everything all
the new browsers the browsers that you
are likely to come across that don't
support feature queries are your old
II's it doesn't really matter that old
ie doesn't support feature queries
because what you do is you use the way
that CSS works you write your old CSS
that works for any old browsers that
happen to come along any non supporting
browsers that show up then you have your
feature query and then inside there you
write your code that overwrites the kind
of old layout and adds all your fancy
new stuff that's kind of the way CSS
works and a browser that comes along
that doesn't understand feature queries
it's just gonna go I don't know what
that is and you can have it because
that's how CSS works it's this wonderful
language that just if a browser comes on
it doesn't understand some of CSS it
just totally ignores that stuff so you
can wrap up anything which might cause a
problem and for a browser that might get
bits of it but not say the grid code in
a feature query and sort of safely use
it anything new that comes along in CSS
from this point you can use a feature
query to detect support of and use it it
lets you sort of safely use things in
your CSS and try things out and enhance
your layouts for people who have support
for whatever comes along now this is a
useful article by Jen Simmons which
takes you through how to use feature
queries in exactly that way you know
layering on support for things that and
support in that case I think graders is
mostly what she's talking about because
the thing is you know we I think a lot
of us you know we're having to still
support old ie browsers and that's
probably the browsers that we all think
or you know I wish they would go away
but it's always been the case I remember
when Netscape 4 was the old browsers
that we all wished would go away and
then
six was the old browser that we all
wished would go away yeah this is never
going to change
although browsers are you know shipping
new releases faster than ever new CSS is
coming out faster than ever - and you're
never going to get a point where you
know new CSS feature is developed by the
CSS working group and overnight it
appears in everybody's browsers that's
just not going to happen and
increasingly we've got people you know
around the world who are using mobile
phones to access web content and some of
those are quite old they're locked to
older versions of browsers you know we
don't know what anyone's looking at our
sites with and we can't rely on those
fancy new features have been available
to them and so there's always going to
be browsers that don't support something
you want to use hopefully those things
will you know progress more quickly most
the time but it's always going to happen
and you know here's a feature that I'm
sure fairly soon we're going to be
saying who you know this this browser
doesn't support this feature and that's
the subgrid feature of CSS grid layout
when we specified grid layout there was
in the level one spec this idea of sub
grids and the thing about sub grids you
see with grid layout and with flexbox
it's only the direct children of your
grid container that become grid items so
if we have a design like this this is
the sort of design that your designer
brings to you and they say look I've got
these three boxes and I want them you
know I want them laid out like this no I
go yep and do that with grid layout
that's a really simple three column grid
and put the content in and it goes into
the CMS and then you end up with this
because the designer never gives you
content that like you know some of the
headings are taller and so on ask that's
not what you ever get it's always very
neatly lined up because it's got the
same amount of text and yet when things
get into the real world they don't line
up as neatly you have something now a
bigger font size or more content or
whatever is going on it's not going to
line up properly and that goes back to
the designer and they're like I wanted
those headings to line up
that's like go on off you go go and sort
it out and you can't because those cards
are all individual things while the
outer is all using grid layout in each
of the cards is a nice column with grid
and we can make the internal as a grid
layout because we can make a grid item a
grid itself we still can't make those
things line up with each other because
they're independent they're completely
independent grids what we actually want
is to be able to say well this three
column grid thing has also got three
rows and the header of each item goes
into the first row and the content goes
into the next row and the footer goes
into the row after that which means they
can all line up with each other now we
can't do that at the moment but sub grid
which is in level 2 will let us do that
it will let us say actually I would like
this internal card to use the grid that
is defined on the parent and that's
going to be incredibly powerful it will
let us do things like have you know a 12
column grid system where things not only
the direct children sit on that grid but
things inside can also line up with the
same column tracts that's going to be
there for us to use of course it's
probably fairly unlikely it's all it's
going to appear in all browsers
immediately so again you know feature
queries will let us detect whether we've
got the sub grid value of grid template
columns and grid template rows and maybe
do something slightly different and if
we don't and you know the actually the
sub grid feature is kind of pretty much
finished in terms of the specification
so we're really just waiting now for
browsers to start implement it I really
hope that will happen soon so the thing
is all this is really positive I think
you know I'm very excited about all this
new layout stuff I hope you are too but
it does bring us new challenges we've
got all of this shiny new stuff and I
think we're only just learning how to
deal with some of the accessibility
implications that these new powers give
us flexbox and grid both allow for some
level of content reordering in flexbox
and in grid you can use the order
property to do
reorder things in flexbox you can change
the flex direction too you know
ro reverse or column reverse grids has
things like dense packing for auto
placement enough so you can then
position things on lines and so you
could very easily end up disconnecting
the visual display with the source so
someone for instance tabbing around the
document kind of ends up jumping all
over the place and that would be quite
unpleasant this is something that we
kind of need to figure out how we deal
with we don't really have a good answer
for that in CSS yet at you know I think
that at some point we're gonna have to
work out how we can let a web design to
say I want the browser to follow the
visual layout and not follow the source
but at the moment anything tabbing
around anything reading out the content
is following the source and not the
visual display and it's really worth
remembering that a very simple test is
can you tab around can you keyboard
navigate around your site after you've
used grid if you can you're probably
okay but you know we've got new problems
new things to worry about and one of
these things came up fairly recently and
really this is a bug in browser
implementations we've got this very
interesting thing called display
contents interesting feature because it
lets us remove a box and visually from
the display so if for instance you've
got a bunch of list items they need to
have a ul and then you've got your
allies if you had a parent sort of grid
structure going on you just wanted those
list items to sit on the grid you can
use display contents to visually remove
the UL and then leave the items but
semantically the UL should still be
there and anyone coming to the site you
know using a screen reader should know
that that's a list so this is really
kind of how this works I've got a grid
here as we know direct children
participate in grid layout the children
of those items do not adding display
content to the grid item removes the box
to that item and anything about the box
the width the borders anything like that
and the children can then participate in
grid layout that's really neat as I say
semantically it should still remain
whatever the element was in the
first place there is a book in all the
browsers that have implemented that mean
that actually semantically doesn't mean
that they're also saying oh well you've
removed that list you've removed that
table structure and therefore you are
now no longer a list or a table that is
a book the spec says they shouldn't do
it but they do it's getting fixed
and this post is a really good run down
of what display contents is and the
potential problems with it but the thing
here really is just that we've got this
new stuff and there are going to be new
things that pop up and you might be the
first person to encounter one of them
because this stuff is so new and some of
these problems might show up only in
combination with other bits of CSS and
so you know do be looking out for stuff
and testing if you're using new stuff
you know don't be so sure that people
won't have introduced bugs like this you
know when it was first mentioned to me I
was like what but the spec doesn't say
that but you know bugs happen and so
we've got this yeah amazing new system
for layout you know I'm it really is so
fantastic how far things have come in
the last few years and we're not
stopping here to say you know we've got
sub-grid coming along we're not stopping
here and when you hit the edges when
you're working with this stuff and
you're like hang on why can't we do
whatever then let us know because so
much of what I've shown you today just
comes from filling in the needs of
people who've said why can't we do
whatever well because no one specified
that yet no one's implemented it no you
know no one's come up with it so as
we're using this new stuff you know when
you find the places where there are
things that we can't yet do let us know
and this is how you let the CSS working
group now these are the issues on CSS
specs now some of those look baffling
even to me and I'm part of the CSS
working group but a lot of them are very
straightforward things that people are
asking for and showing examples and in
fact actually the more you can describe
the use case the thing that you can't do
the better because it turns out that
developing CSS
much like developing any product now if
someone uses your product and they come
along with a really good use case and
say you know I need to do this thing and
I can't do it because and I'm working
round it by doing this then often it's
really easy as a product developer to
say oh yeah we could add that I could
fix that for you and it's the same for
CSS if someone comes along and says look
this is something we can't do and we're
having to do it with JavaScript and it
makes it a bit slow and janky it'd be
great if we have CSS way to do it that's
actually something that may well get
picked up and specified and implemented
and because you know things are
happening so much more quickly you know
it's not going to happen for a product
the project you need to work on tomorrow
but it might be around you know next
year you know do yourself a favor for
your future self as it were and and sort
of talk to people and explain the things
that you can't do because when we look
at browsers now you know look at what's
going in these the last releases of a
few browsers Firefox 62 CSS shapes and
the shaped path editor variable fonts
chrome 69 scroll snapping display
cutouts for your notches and connect
gradients and edge had variable fonts
you know every time a browser release
ships there is a whole bunch of new
stuff isn't it it's a really really
exciting time to be a web developer you
know I've been doing this for 20 years
but it's why I'm still excited about it
you know why I haven't gone off to do
something else and why I still want to
participate and keep making it better
and I really hope that you are all
excited about it too
and all of my code examples and the
slides and so on and some resources are
at that URL thank you for listening
enjoy the rest of the conference
[Applause]